de maire documentaire auquel vous pouvez
bien sûr réagir sur le hashtag docbat un
documentaire réalisé par vous Pascal
carcanade merci d'être avec nous à vos
côté samire mza vous êtes enseignant
vous avez lancé la liste citoyenne sans
étiquette 100 % aubervillier aux
dernières élections municipales bonjour
près de vous Fabian kellerire bienvenue
vous avez été maire de Strasbourg de
2001 à 2008 vous êtes toujours
conseillère municipal de la ville et
vous êtes aussi sénatrice UMP du Barin
merci d'être là en face de vous
Jean-Michel Mor bonjour vous êtes MPS de
Trilport encinemar membre de
l'Association des petites villes de
France et enfin anne Muxel vous êtes
politologue au sévov centre de recherche
politique de scienceces PO bienvenue à
tous alors Pascal carcanade votre
documentaire c'est un appel à
l'engagement oui oui c'est aussi montrer
autre chose que ce qu'on voit
habituellement dans les médias à propos
des élus c'est le point de départ c'est
tous pas pourriis en fait oui c'est ce
que j'ai vu le projet est né d'un ralbol
celui du tous pourri entendre tout le
temps tout se pourri c'est vrai que les
médias sont une caisse de résonance de
toutes les affaires et il y en a et on
dit pas qu'il y en a pas et on pense que
c'est important que les médias montrent
et soient exigeant à l'égard des
politiques mais les quelques-uns dont on
parle cach les énormément qui ne le sont
pas qui n'ont pas d'affair qui sont
engagés qui donnent plus ce qu'ils ne
reçoivent c'est c'est incroyable en fait
de ce qu'ils peuvent donner alors qu'on
reproche à quelques-uns de prendre dans
ce qu'on voulait montrer c'était qui
étaient ces gens-là qui son qui s'eng et
alors comment vous les avez choisis vos
mares et enfin vos élus alors on av
demandé à à quelques personnes en
province de nous faire des propositions
de d'élus qu' connaissaient dont il
savaiit qui dont il connaissaient la
réputation ou dont il savait avec qui
par contre il pouvaient être amis ou
avoir des des relations et puis ensuite
on a organisé de façon à faire avec
toutes ces propositions un panel bon si
personnes en statistique c'est pas ça
n'a pas de ça n'a pas de valeur mais
d'essayer de de faire en sorte qu' soit
le plus représentatif possible droite
gauche homme femm les âges urbains rural
et de faire voilà et puis après
évidemment l'établir des relations avec
eux pour sortir de de ce côté panel mais
au point au départ c'était ça c'était
avir la la vision la plus large possible
de qui sont les élus et puis on a
l'impression que au-delà de l'idée du
vote votre documentaire montre que le
pouvoir d'action des Français c'est de
s'engager en particulier dans la vie
locale parce que c'est une action
concrète efficace c'est ce qui revient
souvent dans le film ils sont tous très
proches des des gens comme on le voit
dans le film ils sont tous très proches
des gens qui les ont élus et c'est même
ce qui cherche c'est c'est c'est le
contact je B Mad dit par exemple que que
j'ai suivi il est tout le temps à la
recherche de ça il est tout le temps il
va vers les gens il est c'est c'est
c'est un métier humain enfin c'est un
métier c'est pas un métier c'est une
fonction mais c'est quelque chose de
extrêmement humain moi ça m'a beaucoup
toucher à leur contact ce côté humain
quoi la recherche d'aider de rendreon
dit de d'abnégation de d'altruisme qui
existe vraiment quoi qui est qui qui
qu'est-ce qui qu'est-ce qui vous a le
plus marqué en suivant ces différents
personnages étonné étonné c'est que on
entend le le la notion d'état de pays
dans le discours des politiques
nationaux qu'il et en fait je ça pas
toujours beaucoup de sens on ti à la
France avec des trémolo et et là j'ai
trouvé que à travers la façon dont ces
six personnes qui ne se connaissaient
pas qui ont des profilss différent
parler de la même manière de la même
chose je trouvais que là ça existait
tout d'un coup j'ai l'impression que le
que l'État avait ça avait du sens en
fait c'était cette communauté cette
façon de de parler d'avoir le le même
élan vers le vers le ou et là tout d'un
coup j'ai l'impression que qu'un pays
existait CIT c'est peut-être ça vraiment
une nation c'est le partager cette façon
de voir les choses et de s'engager et
vous vous engagez quand
vous peut-être la prochaine
fois ce qui aussi m'a vraiment frappé et
qui fait que malgré l'envie que je
pourrais avoir ça me retiendra c'est le
temps que ça leur prend c'est colossal
le temps qu's engagent dans JeanMichel
Mor sourit le temps qu'il consacre à ce
à cette fonction c'est c'est énorme et
là ouais c'est vraiment un don de soi
que je suis que que que j'admire chez
eux pas forcément prêt aujourd'hui à
pouvoir c'est bien le souligner vos
réactions à ce documentaire Fabien
guellerard oui un bel engagement proche
des citoyens je crois que la fonction de
maire je crois qu'il y a même des
sondages qui le disent c'est vraiment ce
que les Français apprécient le plus euh
cette proximité puis cette diversité
c'est ce qui donne sens aussi à cette
mission municipale euh au fond on aime
ça hein c'est notre dopant en quelque
sortte ces interpellations régulières
euh elles sont toujours comment dire euh
il y a une attente du côté des citoyens
mais c'est toujours positif quoi quand
il s'adresse à nous et je crois que ça
c'est c'est quelque chose de très fort
on sent utile hein on en discutait tout
à l'heure ils font oui il y a une sorte
de de transfert de voilà de confiance je
vous confie mon souci c'est un petit
c'est un grand souci mais euh voilà je
je vous fais confiance et c'est un
honneur hein de porter cette
responsabilité dans les bons moments
mais aussi dans les moments difficiles
quand il y a une douleur collective moi
j'ai vécu par exemple une mort d'enfant
c'était terrifiant euh tout le quartier
qui voilà qui se sert qui participe aux
commémorations mais euh on porte cette
douleur collective et et et c'est très
émouvant aussi développe beaucoup
l'empathie aussi Jean-Michel morer vous
réager ouais on peut parler de sacerdos
républicain quelque part et je crois que
c'est on a des gens de plus en plus
désabusés du
politique qui est dans la parole la
posture quel que soit d'ailleurs les
tonalités politiques et alors qu'on a un
pays qui a énormément besoin de lien
social de concret de quotidienneté et
c'est vrai a c'est un vrai engagement
mais c'est alors on donne beaucoup mais
on reçit beaucoup alors et c'est vrai
aussi je pense notamment sur les les les
derniers scrutins j'ai connu des mares
de toute tendance qui avaient fait un
très très bon travail et qui quand ils
sont battus c'est c'est très compliqué
il y a une vraie douleur et parce que
c'est quelque part un engagement se dit
pourquoi pourquoi tout ça alors qu'en
fait tout simplement c'est pour vraiment
changer la vie au concret au quotidien
chez les gens mais alors malheureusement
de plus en plus gère les contraintes et
c'est là où euh c'est ça devient quelque
foois mission impossible c'est on paye
pour les erreurs des autres alors qu'on
a fait son maximum pour faciliter la vie
des gens mais c'est vraiment enfin le
film est magnifique merci euh Sam ma
donc vous je rappelle vous étiez tête de
liste d'une liste sans étiquette
citoyenne vous n'avez pas été élu mais
vous participez à la vie de votre
commune qu'est-ce que ça représente pour
vous on reviendra sur le le motif de
votre engagement un peu plus tard mais
ce métier d'élu et et ce qui vous a
donné envie ce qui m'a donné envie c'est
vraiment pouvoir être dans le cercle de
décision pour essayer de changer les
choses parce que en tant que citoyen on
on est un petit peu perdu on comprend
pas trop en réalité é dans un premier
temps ce qui est politique on connaît
pas les fonctions les seules choses
qu'on voit c'est c'est pour nous hein
c'est pendant les élections on voit des
élus qui des personnes qui se présentent
qui sont là des partis qui qui tractent
qui font un peu de publicité et bah dans
notre commune au bervillier on fait plus
confiance en fait au partis donc
personnellement et le collectif le but
du collectif c'est que à un moment donné
on se dit on sait pas pour qui voter on
est engagé on est des citoyens on est
militants associatifs on essaie de
changer les choses et on sait pas pour
qui voter donc on s'est dit bah on va
peut-être mettre en place une
alternative qui va permettre à un moment
donné les personnes qu'on côtoi le jour
de de de leur présenter quelque chose
qui va leur parler directement et au
départ on connaît Pasin donc on apprend
sur le tas mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
le le reportage vie de mer ça ça donne
envie maintenant on est on va dire on
est un petit peu ancré même si on est à
l'extérieur on n'est pas élu mais on est
militant et on intervient on essaie de
de travailler avec la mun micipalité on
repère un petit peu les
dysfonctionnements on est toujours sur
le terrain et on essaie d'améliorer le
quotidien donc on n peut-être pas élu
mais on y participe donc on est une
sorte d'opposition on nous appelle comme
ça sur mais vous participez vous prenez
part à la exactement on sait exactement
ce qui se passe on essaie de
retransmettre on va dire avec une autre
manière parce que on comprend pas
souvent les termes politiques donc nous
on adapte un petit peu et on comprend
tout de suite en fait les problém
traducteur aussi exactement non quand je
dis traducteur c'est qu'on vraiment on
essaie de d'adapter avec notre discours
parce
ouis nous traduire de médiateur
médiateur on peut appeler ça comme ça
mais en tout cas c'est ils sont
demandeurs ils sont demandeurs anne
Muxel cette popularité du maire elle
vient d'où c'est c'est cette proximité
c'est parce que c'est le le maillon de
la démocratie qui est le le plus proche
des citoyens oui c'est vrai que quand on
demande aux Français voilà en qui ils
ont confiance qu quels sont les élus
dans lesquels se porte effectivement
leur leur adhésion leur confiance le
maire se distingue vraiment de toutes de
toutes les autres fonctions d'élu qui
souffr depuis un certain nombre d'années
maintenant de beaucoup de de défiance de
de méfiance mais malgré tout ils sont
quand même dans une situation paradoxale
parce que c'est vrai que cette charge de
cette politique de proximité est est
très importante et et dégage sans doute
de même une image très très très
positive mais en même temps euh bah les
Français ne se déplacent quand même pas
tant que ça pour aller voter pour eux
donc il y a quand même toujours ce ce
décalage qui qui qui fait
qu'effectivement on on aime les maires
on a confiance dans dans dans ce qu'ils
font dans ce qu'ils sont et on a raison
d'avoir confiance au vu de ce film mais
en même temps c'est vrai que ça ne se
traduit pas forcément c'estàd que la
politique locale ne mobilise pas
particulièrement les électeurs il y a là
un paradoxe tout à fait intéressant mais
je trouve que le film est est tout à
fait fait magnifique indispensable hein
dans un temps justement de défiance
politique importante indispensable pour
montrer et réhabiliter finalement la
crédibilité que l'on doit aux élus
Pascal carcade avant de vous laisser
partir est-ce que ce documentaire ce que
vous avez découvert vous a donné envie
de continuer ce projet je sais que c'est
un projet complet parce qu'il y a aussi
un projet sur le web il y a des
portraits isolés de de de tous les
personnages qu'on vient de voir on
pourrait continuer on pourrait les
suivre ça on pourrait aller pendant mais
j'ai pour pour agir ce que j'ai entendu
c'est que je lesi quand même beaucoup vu
se faire engueuler et ils sont une sorte
de de de punching B de de leur
concitoyens et peut-être que ce rapport
frontal où on peut aller se plaindre à
l'élu c'est lui qui est là cette
proximité c'est ça qui fait aussi qu'on
qu'on l'aime c'est parce qu'on peut on
peut le voir on peut le toucher et ça ça
c'est important après on peut les suivre
jusqu'au aux élections c'est encore des
comportements différents il y a des tas
de choses qui seraient qui seraient très
intéressantes à à suivre j'espère qu'on
pourra le faire alors à suivre merci
Pascal carcade alors on vient de voir
avec ce documentaire que accéder à la
fonction de maèire transforme la vie du
citoyen en profondeur et qui a
clairement un avant un après on va
réécouter un extrait du documentaire on
peut pas être aussi naturel qu'on
aimerait l'être parce que forcément il y
a des il y a des choses voilà qu'on
pourra jamais dire ou on peut plus
donner son avis comme ça
surtout ça ça change un peu quand même
non il manque un essayent d'êre de
rester sur leur réserve et de me
considérer comme madame tout le monde je
ne sais pas dans quelle mesure ça reste
vrai pour le 8 mai bah je je pense que
toute ma vie je me souviendrai de à un
moment donné je me suis dit mais tiens
tu es là tu es au 8 m tu es entre deux
drapeaux un monsieurilà qui tient des
gerbes et être ému finalement je pense
qu'en fait on découvre des émotions
parce que c'est le c'est un moment dans
sa vie on représente la République on
représente l'état
finalement alors on vient de parler de
cette proximité que le maire l'élu local
a avec avec ses citoyens Fabian Keller
vous donc vous avez été maire de
Strasbourg 275000 habitants est-ce que
on peut garder cette proximité là quand
on est ma d'une très grande ville c'est
c'est le défi de la de la grande ville
moi j'aime beaucoup aller en proximité
rencontrer les gens je l'ai encore
refait lors de la dernière campagne
c'est c'est riche de propositions de
découverte aussi parce que voilà on va
voir les gens on va vers eux ils sont
tous surpris d'ailleurs de de voir des
élus venir les rencontrer
mais en travaillant beaucoup j'ai pu
moi-même rencontrer environ 10000
personnes vraiment en entretien ce qui
fait à la fois beaucoup ouais mais peu
par rapport à la population donc dans
les grandes villes ça passe aussi par
les médias et et les médias c'est très
curieux parce que ça ça nous transforme
c'est-à-dire les gens se font des idées
ah oui par exemple par exle bah bon
c'est anecdnotique mais les gens me
disent ah je vous voyais pas aussi
grande à la télé bon parce que je suis
de de grande taille ou je sais pas
imagine ououi oui ça crée une ça
transforme ouais il il nous imagine donc
ça vous enlève encore de la de la
proximité alors que vous en avez quand
même besoin aussi pour pouvoir diffuser
des choses auprès de de vos administrés
oui c'est le dilemme dans une grande
ville parce qu'une partie de la
communication thème par thème dans la
durée du mandat ça passe forcément par
les médias ou et les les gens mémorisent
aussi ce qui les concerne donc ce qui
les touche le parents d'élèves par les
questions scolaires ceux qui sont
laécuré les question de sécurité ou par
un détail mais qui les touche plus plus
particulièrement donc moi je dois dire
très humblement que j'ai tardé à
m'intéresser à ces questions de
communication mais dans une grande ville
elles sont ça sonne comme oui elles sont
très important vous manque vot votre
votre fonction de mère vous manque je
sais pas si je dois le dire mais les
gens en fait dans la rue m'appelle
encore madame le M et c'est chaque fois
un moment d'émotion ouou ils sont
extrêmement gentils ouais euh il il a
dit engeule je trouvais que c'était fort
ils nous disent aussi ils nous partagent
des choses qu' pas hein au bas de mon
immeuble l'air de jeu est démonté j'en
ai marre on m'oublie parce que je suis
dans tel quartier un peu en périphérie
mais c'est une relation qui est qui est
très affective et qui reste et donc à la
fois c'est comment dire je suis à
déplacement lent c'est-àdire que je
quand je circule à Strasbourg je sais
qu'il faut que je j'anticipe le fait
qu'il faut que je
faut préavoir du temps quoi et c'est ce
serait dommage de pas le prendre parce
que les rencontres impromptuus sont
souvent les plus intéressantes les
rendez-vous c'est intéressant aussi mais
c'est les gens ça nourrit votre rlection
ouais voilà et et et souvent c'est la
révélation d'un d'un sujet qu'en fait je
pourrais creuser après mais c'est un
contact qui m'a permis de prendre
conscience de tel ou tel le terrain
problème alors alors quand on regarde ce
ce documentaire on se dit et il y est
dit à un moment donné qu'un mère doit
savoir tout faire ça vous a pas effrayé
quand même au moment de vous engageer
Jean-Michel morer qu'est-ce qui vous a
poussé un jour à vous dire allez je pars
en campagne et je vais prendre la mairie
de Trilport 5000 habitants al d'abord
c'est c'est un engagement humain dans
une équipe où à un moment donné il y a
un passage de relais globalement que que
que j'ai pris en en ayant connaissance
de cause des contraintes alors c'est un
paradoxe parce que souvent quand on fait
de la politique et qu'onaborde
relativement
jeune c'est la course contre le temps
c'est aller vite et cetera moi très
rapidement alors il y avait deux choses
qui qui me qui me PLA qui me plaisait
pas trop dans le rôle de magistre
premier magistrat c'est justement cette
fonction de notable parce que enfin je
plutôt un acteur de la villeactif et C
histoire de de de notable de de de
représentation de la commune en tant que
telle et quelque chose qui pour moi
était était compliqué très compliqué à à
intégrer et donc j'étais premier adjoint
élu puis après adjoint premier adjoint
et c'est vrai que j'ai jamais fait j'ai
rien fait pour brusquer les événements
c'est que quand je me'y suis retrouvé
euh maire et ben effectivement j'étais
mieux préparé h mais c'est vrai que
c'est un engagement je dire entre un
maire adjoint un premier adjoint et puis
le maire il y a vraiment une très très
GRSE différence en terme de de
d'engagement et de représentation aussi
des autres vers soi-même h Samir mza
vous on en a un tout petit peu parlé
avant vous avez décidé de monter une l
citoyenne sans étiquette à aubervillet
ville historiquement de gauche 78000
habitants il y a eu un déclencheur
précis parce que on voit dans le
documentaire qu'il y a souvent un
ancrage et à un moment donné dans la
tête de ces candidats où ils sont dit
alors là c'est plus possible je vais y
aller qu'est-ce qui a été le déclencheur
chez c'est vrai il y a toujours un
élément déclencheur on est deux hein
donc je rappelle qu'on est deux à fonder
le le 100 % berviler donc avec un ami
d'enfance médecin zichan but et benah en
fait on a on a toujours essayé de d'être
présent dans la ville essayer
d'améliorer le quotidien mais par le BIA
on va dire associative étant donné que
je je suis je travaille dans un dans un
dispositif qui gère un petit peu les
jeunes qui leur proposent des activités
qui pour la catégorie dist prés an sur
les trois grands quartiers et euh plus
loin avec mon ami médecin il avait il
avait pour projet de mettre en place le
soir
euh euh à la place du euh exactement
mettre en place un soin parce que on
s'est rendu compte que sur robertvillier
il y avait des demandes il y avait des
besoins donc on avait un projet simple
on avait un centre social un centre
médical qui s'appelle pesqu d'ailleurs
on a proposé on a fait la proposition
d'intervenir le soir de 18h à minuit
avec un le tarif normal hein d'un d'un
médecin de jours et on a réussi à
mobiliser plus mon ami que moi-même qui
a réussi à mobiliser une vingtaine de
médecins pour qu'il puisse intervenir
bénévolement donc les soirs donc il nous
fallait juste l'autorisation en fait du
du directeur du centre médical et la vie
et le pas donné on l'a jamais eu ouais
donc on l'a jamais eu donc du coup on se
dit mais attendez quand on a des projets
déjà tout ficelés tout bien fait pour
améliorer le quotidien on y arrive pas
donc on y arrive pas donc il y a quelque
chose qui cloche et ça nous a donné
envie he quand on voit qu'on sait pas
pour qui voter on se dit bah on va
peut-être faire une liste et on sait que
pendant les élections on est écouté
parce que le le citoyen Londa qui ne
fait pas grandchose est Técouter et oui
parce que mais parfois le le terrain et
cette proximité qui est qui est un
dilemme vous vous êtes sur le terrain en
fait donc vous êtes un très bon aussi
indicateur de de ce qui se passe et et
voilà Fabien Keller vous vous avez un
parcours qui est très très différent
vous avez commencé comme au
fonctionnaire ministère de l'Agriculture
ensuite ministère des Finances ensuite
vous avez dirigé le crédit industriel
d'Alsace puis le Crédit Commercial de
France et puis sou vous décidez de vous
présenter à la mairie de Strasbourg
pourquoi tout à coup alors entre-temps
je je me suis présenté aux élections
départementales je deviens élu de mon
quartier en fait c'est le quartier qui
m'a mobilisé puis des circonstances
toujours des circonstances le sortant ne
se représentait pas et c'était rigolo
parce que j'étais la seule j'ai été la
première femme élue au Conseil Général
du barrain mais l'UDF qui m'avait
investi m'avait dit vous êtes sûr de
perdre la preuve vous êtes une femme TR
là là ouais et euh donc en fait j'ai
gravi les marches et pendant 10 ans
était élu de proximité en même temps que
je travaillais à 80 % et j'avais deux
enfants euh ça a été un apprentissage un
peu un peu douloureux un peu rude ouais
avant de me présenter à la à la mairie
de Strasbourg euh mais c'est aussi une
chance vous savez quand on peut bosser
travailler avoir une vie personnelle et
puis et puis s'engager alors cons
général à Strasbourg en milieu urbain
c'est rude parce que il y a très peu de
compétences il y a pas de service il y a
pas de voilà donc ça a été une belle
période de d'imprégnation où j'ai pu oui
il fallait travailler avec le tissu
associatif avec les projets essayer de
les faciliter mais pas en situation
d'autorité mais en situation de vraiment
de partenaire et j'ai j'ai beaucoup aimé
cette période anne Muxel la fonction de
maire qu'est-ce qu'elle représente pour
les gens est-ce que cette image de de de
respons abilité du maire qui doit savoir
Tout Faire est-ce que c'est pas un
facteur aussi un peu inhibant pour les
gens qui penseraient se dire moi j'ai
pas les compétences je suis pas capable
bah c'est vrai que c'est difficile on
voit bien on voit bien est-ce que
Fabienne galer vient de rappeler et on
voit bien dans le film ce sont
effectivement des personnes qui sont
prêt à à y aller à investir beaucoup de
leur temps mais aussi en terme de en
terme
d'acquisition de compéten avec sûrement
aussi l'application de beaucoup de bon
sens de sens humain
ouaisésoud
lesèmes j'ai pas de compét juridique il
faut savoir il faut avoir des notions de
droit j'ai pas de ce genre de chose ENF
j'imagine c'est des questions qu'on peut
se
poserich avec quand même ce qui est il
faut retenir aussi c'est que on demande
les mêmes choses au maire d'une grande
ville ou au maire de la petite ville et
le maire de la petite ville il a pas les
services alors moi je suis un maire
d'une ville de 5000 où les gros dossiers
globalement c'est c'est nous qui nous
nous les prenons quoi c'est-à-dire qu'au
début je connaissais un Urba bon ben je
m'y suis mis à fond et et c'est vrai que
bon maintenant on a des projets
d'écoartiers qui poussent et cetera et
on devient presque des spécialistes et
là c'est attention là il faut faire
attention parce que quand oui il faut
pouvoir mais je veux dire à un moment
donné quand on a l'ambition pour
améliorer le quotidien de ses habitants
et qu'on a intégré les contraintes
financières économiques et cetera pour
les faire bouger il faut se dire est-ce
que mes habitants d'une ville de 5000
ils peuvent avoir autant de service que
des habitants d'une ville pas trop
éloignée où il y a beaucoup de service
et beaucoup d'habitants je crois qu'
moment c'est est-ce qu'on a l'ambition
de développer son territoire le
quotidien des gens de manière
qualitative pas quantitative ou pas à
part à part après après bien évidemment
c'est ce qu'on donne ou ce qu'on apporte
ou pas et moi je tiens à dire
effectivement que il faut surtout pas
que ce soit une réserve indien de
retraiter le poste de maire il est
important que des gens qui travaillent
et qui continuent à travailler il soit
parce que sinon soit on a le retraité
soit on a le profel de la politique et
le citoyen s retrouve pas alors
justement en fait on s'aperçoit que
c'est quand même plus difficile de
devenir quand on est salarié que quand
on est fonctionnaire au retraité alors
il y a un texte qui est passé au Sénat
qui a été adopté au Sénat le 19 mars
justement pour faciliter l'accès est-ce
que par exemple il faut penser à une
politique de formation euh des élus faen
oui sûrement alors ça existe le droit à
formation mais on n pas toujours le
temps pendant le mandat de se former 18
jours je crois c'est assz court he et
puis il y a le sujet de l'après si on a
envie d'arrêter ou si l'élection n'est
pas favorable moi j'ai en tête par
exemple une de mes anciennes
vice-présidentes qui avait présidé un
très gros établissement d'enfance très
difficile et qui après maiselle a mis
une année
complète a décidé de s'investir
professionnellement dans ce secteur elle
a fait une année de formation de chef
d'établissement mais c'est pas possible
pour tout le monde et c'est un vrai
sujet parce qu'il faudrait bien que les
élus représentent la diversité de la de
la société c'est c'est important ça on y
vient maintenant alors ce documentaire
est un appel à l'engagement il
intervient à un moment moment où le
regard des Français sur la politique a
changé une abstention forte une méfiance
à l'égard des partis qui grandit on
réécoute un extrait du
documentaire elle sert des mains vitesse
grand
V bonjour au revoir qu'est-ce qu'elle
retire de de ça ça peut paraître bizarre
mais non je suis très bien je suis ài et
je me vois pas ailleurs et je me vois
pas plus
haut moi ça me frustrerait énormément
d'être une vraie politicienne estce que
c'était pas le même que tout à l'heure
là il y a un décalage entre la réalité
et les les politicien du fait de de ce
mensonge quoi on est dans un rôle on n
plus dans la dans la vérité on est plus
dans la réalité an Luxel 67 % des
Français tousage confondu ne ferait plus
confiance ni à la gauche ni à la droite
pour gouverner comment on explique cette
défiance si on l'explique ah ce serait
un
grand grand mais vous vous travaillez
là-dessus donc vous avez au moins
quelques idées ouais bah la défiance des
Français bah c'est d'abord beaucoup de
déception à à l'égard des des des grands
partis de de gouvernement des
gouvernements successif aussi bien de
gauche que de droite euh donc c'est
d'abord une grande déception et et aussi
une méfiance qui s'est installée quant à
à cette coupure qui est ressentie entre
ces politiciens dont dont dont on vient
de parler d'une part une classe
politique très très éloignée des
préoccupations
concrète des citoyens et là on voit bien
que les élus locaux eux ne sont pas
effectivement pris dans cette dans cet
écart
entre l'élite et et et les citoyens mais
malgré tout se rabat sur eux quand même
le le le débat national et les
étiquettes et les confrontations
d'étiquettes et les les enjeux de
pouvoir au niveau des grands partis SK
explique que euh et bien souvent ils
sont euh mal ou peu différencier euh
justement des élus au niveau national et
c'est ce qui peut expliquer que alors
qu'ils sont bien aimé alors que l'on
sait que leur politique est concrète euh
et bien on ne va pas se déplacer quand
il s'agira de participer à des élections
municipales ou à des élections
départementales je pense que c'est parce
que il y a toujours ce ce on calque
finalement malgré tout et les médias euh
sans doute contribue beaucoup au travers
des grands débats télévisés euh la
politique qui médiatisé au travers de
ces grands débats contribue beaucoup à
rabattre effectivement la politique sur
les enjeux nationaux al justement Samir
ma vous vous êtes lancé en politique
sans étiquette Jean-Michel morer vous
êtes un RPS mais vous dites que au
niveau municipal vous n'affichez pas
votre étiquette vous dites même si mon
engagement dans la ville avait été
partisan je n'aurais pas été réélu c'est
une évidence voilà alors le parti c'est
c'est c'est devenu un problème à ce
point-là bah euh sur Robert Villier nous
euh oui c'est devenu un problème donc on
ne fait plus confiance on ne fait tout
simplement pas confiance parce que c'est
vrai que on a les problèmes au niveau
national qui qui touche aussi le local
donc nous sur bervill ça a été le cas
parce que quand on a eu la présence de
Monsieur Manuel vas Premier ministre qui
est venu pendant les élections
municipales on a eu l'arrivée aussi de
Najet valoelkassem donc à un moment
donné c'est c'était peut-être aussi
voulu c'était voulu mais euh on n'a pas
fait confiance au Parti socialiste sur
Robert Villier qui a perdu après 6 ans
de mandat parce que vous c'est trop de
déception c'est ça c'est trop de
déception c'est trop de déception donc
c'était un vote sanction hein c'était
pas je pense pas que la ville d'berville
a voulu le retour de du Front de gauche
et du Parti communiste mais pas le choix
il y avait pas d'autres alternatives en
fait donc voilà pourquoi nous on s'est
présenté et en l' espace d'une semaine
on a réussi à avoir 800 voix sachant que
des personnes ne savaient même pas qu'on
se présentait donc on n' pas eu le temps
de toucher un petit peu toute tous les
quartiers on va dire toute la ville on
n' pas pu quand quand vous avez lancé
votre liste citoyenne comment ça s'est
passé avec les partis en présence
c'était compliqué c'était compliqué sur
Robert Villet parce que on était tout de
suite ben on était les personnes
peut-être les on a essayé de nous
cataloguer les rejeter ils ont voulu
venir peut-être à un moment donné c'est
vrai parce que nous on connaît pas le
milieu politique on s'est dit on veut
agir on veut faire confiance on nous
fait confiance les citoyens donc on a
essayé dans un premier temps va c'est
vrai on est parti voir le le maire le
maire du Parti socialiste Zac Salvator
on lui a proposé on a dit voilà on a des
projets on souhaite faire partie de
votre liste nous ça nous dérange pas les
les on nous fa oui vous voulez juste
agir vous exactement nous on connaît
rien on le dit franchement on connaît
pas au départ c'est ça octobre 2013 on
connaît pas grand-chose donc on essaie
d'apprendre sur le tas et on voit on a
essayé de voir un petit peu tous les
partis ce qu' pouvait pas proposer mais
quel est leur projet parce que voilà on
va pas s'allier avec n'importe qui et le
Parti socialiste vousêtes en train de
dire qu'on vous a pas laissé de place
quoi on nous a pas laissé de place on
nous a pas fait confiance et surtout
qu'il y a tellement d'allian en fait que
c'est c'est dur d'intégrer une liste
Michel Mor vous vous êtes encore encarté
Parti socialiste oui non je vais
reprendre mes propos c'est que moi je
suis militant mais je suis maire et
quand on est maire on est maire de sa
ville on est maire de ceux qu'on pas
voter pour soi et quelquefois on doit
défendre des positions je suis très
mobilisé sur la base des dotations
contre un gouvernement que je soutiens
par ailleurs ce que je dis à par là
c'est que ce que les gens n'aiment pas
parce que quand vous êtes maire que
politique que le petit le petit parféire
militant et cetera quand ça va pour
votre partie tout est bon ça va il y a
pas
me par contre quand il y a le refl ça
marche plus ce que les gens demandent à
un maire c'est de l'efficacité c'est du
concret c'est de l'empathie c'est de la
combativité aussi et la combativité
c'est ne pas duper les gens on peut être
un militant conscient et ouvrir sa liste
parce que moi au contraire je suis
désolé d'avoir de pas avoir des acteurs
comme vous dans dans ma commune parce
Queau contraire on en a besoin d'ergie
mais ce que je dis par là c'est que à un
moment donné pourquoi j'ai dit ça
effectivement c'est que l'année dernière
le vent a été mauvais pour mes couleurs
politiques et notamment C et je fais
partie d'un Islander je suis un des
derniers enfin quelque part sur mon
secteur sur mon territoire c'est pas mon
étiquette qui m'a sauvé c'est le fait
que a priori mes concitoyens sont
retrouvés dans ce que je disais dans ce
que je représentais dans l'équipe que
j'ai constitué qui était une équipe
plurielle c'est mon équipe n'était pas
autage de mes idées Fabien quelire vous
donc aujourd'hui vous êtes sénatrice UMP
auparavant vous étiez à l'UDA vous avez
toujours appartenu à un parti est-ce que
vous avez perçu cette méfiance grandir
et est-ce que pour vous on peut parler
d'une fracture entre le niveau local le
niveau national oh oui fracture bien sûr
euh je j'ai fait campagne
sénatoriale en septembre dernier et puis
pendant tout l'été et c'était amusant
parce que les maires me disaient vous
les politiques vous savez les maires de
de commune voilà c'est rural il
s'identifi mais al pas du tout hein pas
du tout à ce qui se passe par ailleurs
mais ils bosse avec nous évidemment
parce que il leur faut des relais et
puis c'est important que nous on
comprenne ce ce qu'ils vivent euh donc
oui cette fracture elle est aggravée
depuis les affaires depuis un an ou deux
je la trouve particulièrement euh forte
et parfois même difficile à vivre pour
nous parce que les gens nous parlent en
disant vous les politiques oh ouais
voilà comme vous êt obligé de vous
justifier oui puis pour un collectif et
un collectif suffisamment vaste pour qu'
a de tout hein il y a des politiques
foridable du documentaire au début
c'était aussi pour montrer que voilà il
y y a a des problèmes il y aussi des
choses qui fonction ce documentaire il
est pour nous il fait du bien fait du
bien euh et c'est vrai que pour avoir
des personnes comme vous qui s'engagent
en politique quand même cette image très
très détériorée et pas est pas favorable
or la politique doit être nourrie
régulièrement d'interpellations de gens
nouveaux d'énergie de de gens décalé
sinon évidemment ce ne sont pas les
querelles et les questions de place qui
vont créer un grand projet donc cette
question de de ressourcement permanent
de réinvention et les stratégies et à
cet égard la mauvaise image elle est
aujourd'hui très décourageante anne
Muxel dans le documentaire la notion
d'intérêt général revient très souvent
est-ce que aux yeux des Français en fait
l'élu local et celui pour qui l'intérêt
général compte encore ah oui je pense
que dans la conscience des Français oui
je pense que vraiment c'est soute qui
fait la fonction même la fonction même
de de de de l'élu et donc la
représentation que les citoyens peuvent
en avoir et bien cellel ce que je trouve
très très bien fait dans le film très
très nouveau très intéressant c'est
effectivement de de de nous présenter ce
qu'est la politique sans les étiquettes
politiques justement sans la politique
politicienne qui n'apparaît quasiment à
aucun moment sauf lors peut-être de la
visite de la ministre et encore et et ça
je trouve que c'est c'est très fort et
c'est c'est vraiment la qualité la force
de ce film qui fera du bien aux élus
j'en suis sûr mais aux citoyens aussi
est estce est-ce que cette défiance
aujourd'hui elle ne traduit pas aussi le
fait que les Français se disent bah on
peut plus attendre tout d'en haut Samir
ma par exemple quand vous vous vous
engagez ou Fabien si vous voulez réagir
et qui est peut-être une réalité
c'estàdire que on attend trop de des
élus nationaux et que bah il faut chacun
faire ce qu'on peut à son niveau bah
c'est vrai c'est c'est c'est une
question très intéressante parce que euh
on c'est pas que au point de vue
national ils sont pas déconnectés non
plus mais nous on est sur le terrain au
point de vue local donc on sait ce qui
se passe réellement il y a des choses
qu'on peut améliorer je vais donner un
exemple sur autvidé euh au niveau
national il y a 5 % d'étrangers c'est
clair à aubervill il y a 40 %
d'étrangers donc on peut pas appliquer
une politique au niveau national et
l'adapter tout de suite telle qu'elle
est au niveau local on doit l'adapter on
se doit d'adapter sans changer sans de
grands changement mais on doit on doit
on doit avoir tous ces tous ces
statistiques ces nombres pour essayer
d'améliorer le quotidien parce que sinon
on se retrouve pas c'est pas pour rien
qu'une ville comme on berviler on se
retrouve à 72 % à 72 de taux
d'abstentionniste c'est pas normal ça
leur par parle plus donc et je retiens
et je voulais rajouter par rapport à
tout à l'heure donc quand on a fait le
tour des partis pour essayer de voir un
petit peu quel qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait
apporter comme contribution et ben les
portes n'étaient pas n'étaient pas
fermées le je rappelle he parce que je
rectifie le par nous a proposer deux
postes sur une liste bon on avait pas on
était pas dans on était pas éligible on
avait un qui pouvait être éligible mais
c'était pas suffisant donc on voulait
pas rentrer pour être intégré parce que
on avait peur parce que si on pouvait
rien changer donc on allait tout de
suite être catalogué ouis c'est des élus
ils étaient censés nous représenter au
final ils ne font rien et le
documentaire il est très intéressant
parce qu'il montre que que l'élu et un
peu partout à la fois il doit avoir
plusieurs compétences et des fois bah ça
touche pas forcément sa délégation et
une ville comme la nôtre et ben on vous
on fait appel à vous vous êtes délégué
du sport on a un problème de logement
c'est vous qu' c'est vous qu'on va
contacter parce que c'est vous vous êtes
censé être le représentant des citoyens
on vous connaît tous donc c'est à vous
qu'on s'adresse et si vous pouvez pas le
résoudre et ben votre capital sympathie
il baisse donc voilà pour pourquoi nous
maintenant on a fait le choix de pas
forcément de de pas choisir cette
alliance et on est resté malgré tout
indépendant et intervenir au du point de
vue extérieur et alors anne Muxel il y a
aussi un problème de représentation
c'est-à-dire que 86 % des maires sont
des hommes pour 14 % de femmes moins de
2 % de mères ont moins de 40 ans les
minorités sont sous représentées tout
comme certaines catégories sociales
est-ce que l'éloignement entre les élus
et les citoyens n'est pas avant tout
sociologique oui je crois qu'il y a un
grand
besoin d'une pour les citoyens de se
sentir représenté mieux représenté dans
la diversité de leurs de leurs
appartenances
socio-professionnell
culturel effectivement il faut des
femmes il y en a quand même de plus en
plus heureusement en politique mais pas
encore assez vous vous a carrément dit
encore assz mais vous êtes une femme
vous allez perdre c'est quand même je je
reviens sur ce que vous dit disz tout à
l'heure parce que vous étiez une femme
vous a dit que vous alliez perdre oui
bon mais grâce à la loi quand même sur
la parité les choses vont vont dans le
bon sens on va dire on y est pas encore
mais espérons ça va dans le bon sens et
quand on voit d'ailleurs dans dans les
enquêtes dans les enquêtes que l'on
d'opinion que l'on que l'on mesure
aujourd'hui un homme ou une femme en
politique a la même crédibilité pour
pour les Français il n'y a plus
effectivement ce préjugé qu'il y avait
qu'il pouvait y avoir il y a confir nbre
d'anné je les lois sur la parité ont
permis aux femmes par exemple d'entrer
dans les conseils municipaux mais vous
l'avez rappelé elles ne sont que 14 % à
être maire dès qu'il y a l'accès à la
fonction de pouvoir voilà les femmes
sont
moins pas seulement qu'en politique
malhe c'est vrai également tout à fait
dans dans l'entreprise mais pour
rebondir sur tout à l'heure vous disiez
il faut avoir plein de compétences faut
dire que les femmes pour en avoir
rencontré beaucoup qui sont candidates
se posent tout cette question de la
compé c'est vrai c'est une question que
les hommes se posent moins et les hommes
un peu moins en moyenne il y a tout il
faut pas être voilà trop trché mais
souvent elles hésitent et dans des
communes un peu rurales c'est c'est une
accession qui est pas qui est pas simple
euh même si comme vous le rappelez une
fois en poste ça se passe très bien
aussi donc je pense que c'est diversité
bien sûr hommesfemmes mais aussi euh
avoir plus de salariés c'est un vrai
problème que le monde de l'entreprise
soit pratiquement plus représenté oui en
tout cas des fonctions un peu
importantes parce que c'est incompatible
moi-même je l'ai vécu à un moment parce
que l'entreprise vous
dit c'est à plein temps où est-ce que
vous faites de la politique enfin où
allez-vous et puis parce que bah dans un
un monde mondialisé où il faut beaucoup
voyager et cetera il y a plus forcément
une unité de lieu qui est indispensable
quand on est élu local donc c'est c'est
un vrai souci et la diversité également
toutes origines enfin jeunesse
et on va y venir ça ça sera simplement
par rapport au au la déconnexion du fait
d' d' politique ressenti hors sol par
rapport au français aux citoyens il faut
différencier le local ù clairement le
lien est direct ou clairement aussi moi
je pense que c'est pas forcément un
problème de de parité ou pas il y a une
évolution sociologique et tant mieux et
la parité la loi sur la parité est une
bonne loi quand on regarde l'évolution
que ça amène et je vois même dans les
villes rurales de plus en plus de de de
mè femmes et et c'est tant mieux mais où
je veux revenir sur le phénomène horsol
c'est effectivement on a une vie
politique nationale retranscrise par les
médias de personnes qui sont dans le
vivier soit ils sonortent de grandes
écoles soit ils sont des des appareils
de chic d'appareil alors de droite comme
de gauche le discours est pas là et là
forcément les enjeux des de pouvoir et
cetera correspondent plus aux enjeux du
quotidien du citoyen donc en fait
effectivement il faut appeler à une plus
grande diversité mais qui n'est pas
simplement ethnique ou de sexe c'est
aussi une diversité dans la
représentation nationale de la vraie vie
tout simplement alors euh on vient de le
dire hein parmi le problème de les
catégories sous représentées il y a les
jeunes euh Samir ma je voudrais vous
entendre là-dessus parce que au moment
où les jeunes sont frappés de plein
fouet hein par le par le contexte
économique en gros être militant ça
n'intéresse plus adhérer au syndicat ça
n'intéresse plus non plus alors les
jeunes est-ce qu'ils s'engagent oui
quand on entend Samir et tant mieux mais
comment vous comment vous voyez les
choses sur les terrain et ça et puis
Anne vous nous direz sous quelle forme
bah nous au départ encore une fois je
pense que les jeunes ils sont beaucoup
dans le milieu associatif donc ils sont
engagés hein peut-être pas politiquement
mais au départ ils sont engagés ils
s'intéressent à la ville et quand ils
essayent de franchir le pas bah encore
une fois cette appellation jeune nous a
nous nous a pas bloqué mais on a
été on a on était l'étiquet jeune voilà
on s'est présenté en tant que parti
citoyen mais on nous a tout de suite bah
ils sont jeunes ils peuvent pas se
présenter bah de toute façon c'est du
nimporte qui ça la question de la
compétence en fait bah c'est exactement
ça parce que pour pour ces personnes bah
il faut être pour être compétent il faut
être peut-être un peu plus âgé avoir
plus de 40s exactement et c'est vrai
cette étiquette nous je l'avais pas dit
au départ mais on nous a appelé c'est
des groupes de jeunes ils font pas
grand-chose ça sert à rien et j'ai envie
de dire que c'est pas ça la
problématique exactement est-ce qu'on a
des compétences la vraie question c'est
pour être élu il faut peut-être avoir
des compétences ou pas parce que ce qui
est bien pour être élu c'est que des
fois on n pas forcément de diplôme et on
peut être élu et c'est ce qu'on a essayé
de faire passer comme message au à tous
les jeunes à tous les jeunes on leur a
dit que parce que moi on venait me voir
on me dit mais attendez Samir tu te
présentes des jeunes mais tu es tu es
jeune tu peux pas te présenter mais tu
as quoi comme diplôme faut avoir quoi
mais il faut vraiment faire un travail
de pédagogie et expliquer comme quoi on
peut on peut être compétence et être
jeune aussi en même temps et anne Muxel
en fait il y a pas dépolitisation des
jeunes ils sont très concernés les
jeunes mais il y a une nouvelle forme de
politisation oui on a évoqué tout à
l'heure la question de l'intérêt général
et c'est vrai que les jeunes ne sont pas
dépolitisés ils ne sont pas désengagés
simplement leur engagement ne passe plus
par des des rattachements à des
organisations partisanes classiques à
des organisations syndicales et donc je
crois que là en tout cas la politique au
niveau local pourrait justement si on
leur donne une place tout à fait les les
impliqués les concernés et on trouverait
sûrement beaucoup de disponibilité je
rappelle que certains partis ont bien
compris et le font et l'ont fait aux
dernières élections municipales il y a
effectivement pas mal de jeunes de
certains partis qui ont intégré les
conseils municipaux et là je pense qu'il
y a urgence pour les grands partis
notamment les grands partis de
gouvernement de effectivement de
présenter de présenter des jeunes et des
très jeunes et surtout de leur de leur
faire confiance parce que je pense qu'en
France on fait pas assez confiance à la
jeunesse et et la jeunesse de ce pays a
besoin de de penser qu'elle a une
utilité sociale qu'elle peut faire
quelque chose pour ce vous voulez réagir
moi c'est une conviction puisque j'ai
fait de de campagnes municipales et
sénatorial récemment c'est qu'il y a une
formidable énergie sur le terrain et que
si la France s'en sort ce sera grâce à
cette énergie toute la question c'est
comment les organisations alors les
équipes municipales mais les
organisations d'entreprises aussi
peuvent intégrer cette énergie un peu
l'organiser mais garder cette volonté de
faire cette ces idées aussi qui sont
relatives à ce qui est vécu et et c'est
vrai que par exemple les jeunes avec
leur contrat à durée
déterminée tout ça c'est peu présent
dans le débat public politique alors
qu'aujourd'hui ça devrait être
absolument central on propose des
conditions d'entrée dans la vie
professionnelle et la construction de la
vie familiale qui sont pas terrible he
aujourd'hui à la jeunesse c'est pas un
sujet majeur du débat public alors que
ça devrait l'être et que c'est porté par
des des personnes qui s'engagent sur le
terrain il nous reste une minute juste
dernière question est-ce que quand on
voit que les jeunes se tournent vers
l'associatif la démocratie particip p
l'engagement citoyen est-ce que ça veut
dire qu'à terme le paysage démocratique
va changer qu'en fait il faut repenser
la structure vous l'espérrez Jean-Michel
en fait on est dans une période où tout
le monde doute il entre deux là mais
j'amais une citation d'é luir pour finir
sur sur ce genre de et notamment sur la
jeunesse il est grand temps de rallumer
les étoiles je crois que c'est un peu un
défi c'est il faut rallumer les étoiles
la démocratie c'est un trésor et ce
trésor il faut qu'il soit qu'il soit
vivant et qui correspond à réité du pays
merci on va terminer sur ces mot des
Loir merci à tous d'être venu sur ce
plateau la semaine prochaine pas de
débat une petite pause avant de vous
retrouver dans 15 jours nous parlerons
de la reconnaissance du génocide
arménien en Turquie à très vite sur
Public
Sénat